comment être vis de s'en passer pour un
fils de tout en assumant d'être ce fils
telle est la question pour nicolas bedos
qui semble en avoir tiré une grande
expérience de funambule à en croire le
déroulement de sa semaine mythomane
chronique sur le fil délirante et
légèrement suicidaire qui lui aura
permis de gentiment tuer le père et
l'émission de franz olivier giesbert
avec je pense que françois gilbert n'a
pas eu besoin de moi prend pour lui mais
c'est derrière moi qui se débrouille
très bien tout seul de ma chronique
aussi énervante fut-elle et je le sais
pour l'elysée je ne pense pas que l et
été fatale à l'émission jeunesse si
c'était le cas je mens ventre est faite
moi confiance
mais non j'ai pas la prétention d'avoir
d'avoir ruiné les missions de giesbert
suis peut-être un tout petit peu par ici
si nicolas bedos était d'abord fait
connaître comme auteur de théâtre
notamment en mettant en scène son père
dans le voyage de victor ou mélanie
laurent dans promenade de santé
quelques millions de téléchargements sur
internet en ont fait la révélation
médiatique de l'année et une révélation
pour lui même j'ai pris indéniablement
goût et je pense que c'est même plus que
la télévision que ça m'a fait découvrir
ça m'a fait découvrir tout simplement le
fait que je prenais du plaisir avec
m'exprimer devant les gens mais ça veut
dire que j'ai découvert à 30 piges que
tout d'un coup
d'abord c'était jubilatoire de passer de
l'autre côté qui était metteur en scène
c'est vrai que ça va être difficile de
naître maintenant que le
l'accompagnateur de mes acteurs même si
j'adore ça et j'ai découvert les autres
j'ai découvert le public j'ai découvert
le rire des gens mais pas seulement le
rire même les soupirs même les mêmes les
tous et sont qu'une phrase peut
provoquer ça me fait bander
donc j'ai décidé de ne plus trop
m'embarrasser de mai
je dirais de mes plus d'heures de fils
et d'oublier de faire confiance aux gens
qui m'encouragent et qui ont l'air de ne
plus trop me parler de ma filiation
on me fait en ce moment le grand honneur
de ne presque plus en parler et
effectivement on lui parlerai plus
volontiers de ses formules à la poésie à
ces signes qui lui ont parfois attiré
quelques ennuis le rendant
définitivement irrésistible ou carrément
insupportable c'est selon je pense que
j'ai toujours été comme ça dans la vie
avant avant que ça devienne aussi public
dans une dans un dîner je fais partie
des gens qui peuvent rendre une soirée
parfois un peu un peu nerveuse je crois
qu'il ya eu mais encore une fois un
violence du timide et moi je suis un
timide je suis quelqu'un qui avant
chaque chronique a toujours
un petit bêtabloquants sur lui pour se
calmer
je suis quelqu'un de très très très
fragil nerveusement ce par hasard si
j'ai écrit promenade de santé sur deux
tarés dans un hôpital psychiatrique qui
tombait amoureux il était alcoolique
obsessionnel et elle était nymphomane et
psychotique sont de niveau ce que j'ai
approché très près soit personnellement
soit par le biais de certains intime
c'est quelque chose que je prends plus à
coeur même que que l'aspect que la
politique par exemple pour moi c'est un
engagement parce que ça pollue nos
existences et je moi je crois que il ya
pas seulement l'argent et la situation
sociale je crois que au départ il ya une
inégalité psychiatriques chez chacun
d'entre nous et il m'est arrivé d'être
jaloux très jaloux face à des types que
je trouvais beaucoup plus égale d'humeur
beaucoup plus équilibré beaucoup plus
serein une terre promise pour le petit
nicolas tellement soucieux d'être à la
hauteur entre départs embryons engagé et
une marraine gisèle halimi
particulièrement exigeante
on parle de politique et on se retourne
vers la petite victoria où le petit
nicolas et on lui dit qu'est ce que tu
en penses toi de la peine de mort ce2 de
la gauche de la droite va donc cesser ça
oblige à mme pascale à à la maison
fallait être brillants il fallait avoir
décodé les passions c'est pas une
passion d'un conte ya 15 ans t'as pas
envie de devenir kafka t'es qu'une merde
dans ma famille on se drague on se
draguer rien et à qui ouvrirent me
donnait l'impression d'être acquis en
fait si je pense que c'était acquis mais
moi j'étais convaincu que je pouvais
décevoir une angoisse qui devient
insurmontable à l'heure où les espoirs
doivent se concrétiser et le talent
s'affirme et que tu tu espères
génial plus quand tout d'un coup la vie
s'écroule et que tu te retrouves dans la
peau d'un écrivain lyon sans succès et
sans projet tuteur envie de flinguer tu
arrêtes de flag et parce que ton orgueil
temps tout ton égo et est littéralement
carbonisé par la honte
vous savez un tricks appelle la
dépression nerveuse et la dépression
nerveuse
ça ne s'explique pas on a les jetons
quand liamine de 12 ans vous pose une
question on a l'impression d'être bête
on a l'impression d'être fou et d'être
en dressant et comme on travaille plus
bas enfin on gagne plus d'argent puis
puis les gens autour s'inquiète et et on
se dit que c'est cuit et qu'on en
sortira jamais donc moi je suis tout
simplement un garçon qui a fait une très
très très très très grave dépression
entre 20 et 23 24 ans ce qui explique
sans doute la gourmandise d'un nicolas
bedos aujourd'hui courtisé par tous sur
le petit écran comme sur le grand
puisqu'il est même déjà au festival de
cannes comme plume de mélanie laurent
j'ai envie de profiter de ma jeunesse
avant qu'elle disparaisse et josé pas et
là tout à coup je me dis pas pourquoi
pas puisque on m'en parle puisque de
spontanément des réalisateurs viennent
me voir donc vous risquez de voir
peut-être un peu jouer la comédie mais
encore une fois tout ça n'était pas
prévu il ya un an
c'est une étrange année c'est une très
étrange année
[Musique]